[Music]
is
[Music]
god knows it's a love affair with paul
ah i said it was obvious
he was smaller than julia but he was
looking at her with eyes
magnifique
and uh
and she
paul she was always asking you know
it was like how's the pigeon duo cool
you know paul
and paul was looking at julia's she was
good and he was in admiration for his
wife
[Music]
me
cooking it's an expression of what you
learn what you see what you smell
what you are able to do with your
fingers
and when you cook you give your love
it's more than to feed your body it's
have
pleasure
[Music]
totally
[Music]
functions
with julia and paul
clearly you read between the lines i
mean he comes home she makes him a great
lunch and they obviously go to bed every
day
[Music]
m
hi my name is lindsey barr i'm a film
writer with the associated press and i
am here with filmmakers betsy west and
julie cohen who are behind the beautiful
documentary julia we've just watched
a really really gorgeous and sort of
romantic scene um that we're referring
to as the pear tart scene um that we're
going to be discussing here today um but
you know i guess first i just really
wanted to kick off with this sort of
inspired choice to
film your own food sequences for this
film and not just to rely on like the
archival footage of julia preparing
preparing food from from her show um can
you talk a little bit about why you
wanted to do that the starting point of
course for so much of our film was julia
child's
body of work the french chef uh that
aired on pbs and and later shows and as
fantastic as julia is in those uh in
those moments as lively and as great a
teacher and everything that's wonderful
about her the food doesn't really look
that fantastic because they're limited
by 1960s technology and not even the
best 1960s technology because as our
film shows they were a little uh cheap
frankly at wgbh in those days so
we really wanted the
love that julia felt for food to come
through and for the audience to see the
beautiful
scenes of food being prepared in all of
its great glory and we had the huge
advantage of having the technology of
modern day top-notch 4k cinematography
to bring the food to life in the film
and we we went for it luckily we weren't
actually operating the cameras we had
two uh you know amazing cinematographers
uh claudia rashke who has we've filmed a
lot of our
films with including julia who did all
of the inter many of the many of the
interviews and the verite and then early
on we heard about a photographer in
france who specializes in food
cinematography nanda breto lard
we thought that he you know he would
really add so much to this to be able to
do
uh the macro shooting and the slo-mo and
to make it
make the food look as luscious
as um
julia felt that it was you know to
really uh bring the viewer in what was
sort of the decision behind you
obviously focus in on a few of her
iconic dishes the bargaining on and the
roast chicken and obviously the pear
tart like how did you how did you decide
which ones to film or were there are
there a bunch on the cutting room floor
we didn't film anything that we didn't
end up using uh in the movie food wise
and that is because we saved the food
shooting to be the very last step of our
process we knew that we really wanted
food that would help drive the narrative
it wouldn't just be like decoration it
would really be kind of part of the
storyline so as a result we were like
let's cut the film together and then
figure out which are the dishes that we
want to connect to which scenes and we
had a fantastic help in this process
which was the cook and food stylist
susan spungan who is not only expert at
making food look beautiful but also is
an expert in julia child's
body of of food every piece of food you
perceive prepared in the film is an
actual authentic julia child recipe
except a little bit of a walk chinese
food scene at the beginning that just
shows how julia fell in love with
chinese food other than that we went
totally with her recipes but we worked
with susan and our producer holly to
make decisions about what food should go
with what scenes so so let's talk about
how the pear tart came with this this
sort of
representation of their love story we
were really drawn to the idea of a
feminist love story i don't think we
knew at the beginning how sensual a love
story it was going to become but when we
found the letters that paul and julia
wrote talking to and about each other
and the amazing photographs that
paul took we realized that we were going
to lean in to the sensuality of their
relationship in their young marriage
living in paris um i mentioned before
that we had two cinematographers the
idea was we were gonna bring nanda from
paris and um have him film
scenes uh
that we were doing uh of cooking this
food in a kitchen that holly arranged to
be created in a studio in manhattan a
julia replica kitchen you know complete
with all of the copper pans the way paul
had arranged them for julia in her
kitchen and you know the authentic
garland stove which holly found in a
garage in new jersey and then had um
renovated so the two cinematographers
were going to come and susan was going
to do the cooking and we were going to
do the variety of shooting there but um
kovid intervened
so it turned out that we couldn't get
nanda to come to the united states so we
wound up doing
two
different shoots uh
claudius shot in the studio
in uh in new york and nanda was in paris
doing this special macro close-up
shooting uh the pear tart
was um something that susan suggested
you know julie and i said look we want a
really
sexy
uh probably a dessert we thought that
would be really good and you know when
you think about sexy desserts you often
think of chocolate
we suggested that and it was susan who
said
no
what about the pear tart you know it
just has so many wonderful steps to it
you know it takes a while to prepare and
it's so
sensual
doing the dough and the tart part and
the incredible pairs and as you
described it we thought okay this will
be great and
it turned out to be even better than we
imagined frankly
so we were preparing two whole separate
pair tarts one in new york one in france
uh shot completely different ways with
our two very differently styling uh
cinematographers and then in the edit
room our genius editor carla gutierrez
marries them all together so it looks
like you're just seeing one pair tart
being uh being put together when in fact
you're seeing uh on separate continents
uh different pair tarts being performed
it's funny you talked about this as our
pair tart scene it internally within
film we call it the sexy paratart scene
um and
uh
you know people have asked when they see
the film wow it's incredible like how
did the cinematographers know to like
film it so centrally but the answer is
that we told them we already knew what
scene this was going with so we were
like okay here's the bear tart just make
it look like look consider all the steps
and just make it look as sexy as
possible at every turn and we think that
you'll agree that they really uh they
really got into that assignment and and
really nailed it oh yeah i mean just
rewatching it right before and you're
like when the drippings are coming down
off the pears and it's it
makes you want that tart and a little
whipped cream at the end
one other thing about just the decision
to
make the julia and paul love story kind
of an overtly sexual story
in in movies there's kind of like often
a certain kind of sexuality that women
are granted and it's only certain women
for that matter and
conventionally
beautiful
perfect figure often petite and like
most of all like they kind of gotta be
young there's this view that like okay
over 35 nobody wants to hear about your
sex life and
we thought that making julia and paul
showing julia and paul's marriage to be
as sexual as it was and putting that in
a very mainstreamy movie context is
actually like we're feminist filmmakers
and we feel like that was a feminist
statement on our part and we wish that
women got to have more sexuality after
they turned 35 so at least for this film
we went for it now is this like is this
like food styling like for an
advertisement where it's not actually
edible in the end or are these are these
actually yeah okay no that was one way
that our that our
plan differed a lot from people you know
in commercials which frankly
kind of uh mid to cheap level food is
often the stuff that looks the most
beautiful in commercials but as we
learned through doing this process which
i actually hadn't known previously what
you're seeing there usually isn't food
it's like glue or whatever so that
we felt like it was important to really
be cooking julia's recipes and really
seeing them the disadvantage that put us
at and the reason that the commercial
people don't do that is that while a lot
of elements of food look beautiful when
you're first preparing them it doesn't
last so our cinematographers had an
extra challenge because like there's
that point where we're pouring the gravy
over the roast beef it looked beautiful
for like the first 42 seconds and then
it congeals and looks really disgusting
so we had to have it prepared a couple
times and each time the cinematographer
had to like cloudy just had to jump
right in get it exactly right get the
lighting perfect get her move perfect
because if you'd missed it the first
time then like a minute later it looks
disgusting that's incredible so did you
have to ever like go back and repeat
because of that
yes you know you sort of had budgeted in
your time to like sometimes do a thing a
cup like the hollandaise sauce and the
gravy and again a couple things had to
be done a couple times but everything is
absolutely edible and our crew took the
food home at the end of the day and ate
it and it was delicious that's wonderful
just like on just like on julia's show
as i as i learned from your film i just
like the show
and i will be referring to it as the
sexy paratart scene from now on yes
please
but
obviously it's not just about the tart
too it is about julia and paul's
relationship so i i was just wondering
what your process was how you uncovered
these sort of incredible love letters
and how you decided to integrate them in
that beautiful script um into the scenes
you know we knew that they had a strong
marriage uh but when we got into the
archive and started looking at some of
the letters that they wrote to each
other but really also the letters that
they wrote about each other to their
friends in paul's case to his brother
you know describing each other we love
that and we love the kind of evolution
of the relationship it was not love at
first sight and they were both a little
wary
of each other uh you know julia didn't
love
paul's mustache the way he looked and
paul was not so
uh thrilled with um
julia's kind of vibrant
laugh it was a little bit too much for
him at first but you know when they
as we say in the film when they went to
china when they were both assigned to
china their love blossomed and it we
love the fact that it blossomed over
food i mean paul was someone who was
very
adventuresome culinary adventuresome and
he wanted he didn't want to eat the the
mess hall food from you know
uh the us uh of the oss or the us army
base uh he wanted to go out and eat real
chinese food and you know julia loved
that
uh so that was the beginning really of
both their courtship and kind of setting
julia up for her grand revelation in
france when she lands there and has her
first
lunch uh that paul takes her to the
famous restaurant uh the oldest
restaurant in france and she has the
soul mournier and just you know falls
madly in love with that and with the
idea of becoming an expert cook
we also had the photographs you know
paul was a fantastic photographer
and there's just hundreds hundreds i
mean thousands of pictures of paul's but
certainly from their time in um
in france
of just loving portraits of julia child
you know languishing in the field and
with her long legs splayed out in front
of a pier and
uh on and on so
it gave us a real opportunity to use
these various materials excerpts from
letters diaries the photographs uh and
you know and other people's observations
to describe this romance the
observations that you know that you just
saw in the scene uh particularly those
that came from our fantastic french
characters uh danielle del push who was
the
uh personal chef to francois mitterrand
um
and uh francois simone the a great
french
food critic who we show only uh
revealing his facial identity so that he
can still go into restaurants and do his
critic thing without uh without being
known
each of them brought so clearly to us
when we when we interviewed them they
brought so clearly that sense that the
french have of the
larger significance of food like food
isn't just food it's about so much more
although it was certainly our
storytelling choice to emphasize uh the
sensuality of the love of food that came
very organically in those interviews you
know
you start talking to a french person
about food and within about three or
four sentences they're going to be
talking about sex and that certainly
happened because that is something that
we don't see your process in
interviewing these people and you get
such wonderful evocative quotes and
stories and you know danielle in
particular i mean was she
was it hard to coax those sort of
anecdotes out of her like
or was she just ready to talk about
their relationship
there wasn't a lot of coaxing going on
you know she came
uh from her farm in perrigor she took a
train up to paris and then met us uh
at the cordon bleu so you see that in
the background there's this beautiful
kitchen and she sat down and
just
unleashed
first of all
you know about the
sexism that she and julia faced in in
france and also in america but then
she had met julia in the united states
and and uh and knew paul as well
and we just loved her description of
their relationship i mean she clearly
saw how much in love they were you know
just animating this relationship i mean
there wasn't one person that we talked
to i think who didn't remark on how
devoted
julia and paul were to each other did
you come out with sort of a renewed
appreciation of her did you had had you
known this all going in or we went in as
fans but far from julia experts so it
was really
amazing to learn really every element of
her story was not only
you know there's revelatory stuff but
also just so much fun to learn this is
someone who it's really enjoyable to
spend time with that was probably um
amplified by the experience of so much
of the edit process happening during the
pandemic a period where
everyone's so
closed in and the idea of foreign travel
which is celebrated so much in the film
and gathering with others to eat is like
feels like a dream that was sadly far
away but at the same time the importance
of home cooking you know what julia
championed it felt really special to be
immersed in this material at this
particular time well
thank you so much betsy west and julie
cohen and congratulations again on your
beautiful beautiful documentary if you
haven't seen beyond the sexy pear tart
scene i would highly recommend going and
checking out the whole thing because
it's delightful and you will want to hit
the kitchen immediately afterwards thank
you lindsay thanks lindsey